[Music]
how did you enjoy kind of let loose and
letting that kind of part of yourself
out I enjoyed it a lot it was very
different and totally it was very
uncomfortable to start out with it but
then I realized like I really like that
elegant side and I'd like to use that
elegant side even more and I didn't
really know I had it in me that much
because it was so it seemed so yeah I
guess it's someone's role design we just
had an eye roll on camera like I could
play that back it is well the thing is
she keeps saying like she's an old soul
in the rehearsals and she's constantly
like oh no I'm like a tomboy as well so
I feel like she's a bit I'm happy she's
a bit like on this on that but I think
you've got both sides I do I do think I
am both sides but I'm just so used to
showing my fierce side that when I show
this elegant side I immediately feel
like I'm dropping my guard right and I
don't like doing that and so then I
might just say fear so it is inside of
me and I was happy to showcase that
tonight it has John seen any rehearsals
or any footage did you see it at this
elegant side of you yes he he loved it
I can't wait to talk to him afterwards
he'll be here next Monday so I'm really
excited if we make it the chemistry
between you guys I really dig it like
there's a real connection I really care
you know I want her to do really well
and I want to show that she's capable of
anything so I'm putting my heart and
soul to make sure that she succeed and
oh that's so true I agree
[Music]
you